selon une formule usée j'en conviens
mais inspiré du titre d'un film et cette
fois ci parfaitement en situation y at
il un pilote dans l'avion alors la
réponse est pour l'instant on en manque
et la compagnie nationale air france va
embaucher 200 pilotes dont 30 femmes il
fut un temps où cette profession était
saturé c'est le cas cela dit on en a
besoin rapidement or pour les former et
bien il faut du temps d'où quelques
produits les plus facile de trouver
rapidement des techniciens que des
pilotes car là il faut effectivement du
temps pour les former l'activité d'air
france est très liée à la conjoncture
économique et celle ci redécolle cette
embauche de 200 pilotes s'inscrit dans
un recrutement générales de 2000
personnes cette année exceptionnelle
cela faisait quinze ans que la compagnie
n'ouvrait plus ses portes alain du big
air france organise des expositions
passe des petites annonces affiches
explique attire les curieux la compagnie
a besoin de remuscler ses services
trouver des techniciens des employés des
cadres mais surtout des pilotes or pour
qualifier un pilote il faut trois années
d'études pas moins on forme actuellement
50 pilotes de jet par an il en faudra
140 par an dans l'avenir mais tout de
suite pour résorber le retard il faut
donner un coup de collier et former 250
pilotes par promotion dans les quatre
ans à venir
actuellement les pilotes d'avions à
réaction sortent de l'école nationale de
l'aviation civile pour augmenter les
recrutements air france a créé sa propre
école et proposer deux nouvelles
filières permettant d'accéder à la
profession
la première filière c'est une filière
qui est constitué de pilotes
professionnels qui ont déjà donc une
expérience aéronautique une expérience
de pilotage
d'avion bi moteur par exemple est la
deuxième filière qui touche davantage de
monde c'est une filière qui concerne des
jeunes qui ont une formation
scientifique de base de niveau bac + 2
par exemple ou qui sont en rade sud et
qui sont sans aucune expérience
aéronautique sélectionnés pour au cours
d'une formation de trois ans qui dure au
total trois ans de venir à la fin de
cette formation des pilotes
professionnels
en attendant que ces élèves soient
formés air france pare au plus pressé en
allant chercher des pilotes dans les
compagnies régionales les blocs
d'affront son choix au ni les compagnies
régionales mais il se trouve que ses
compagnies régionales maintenant voilà
l'objectif partir sans qu ils sont
remplacés par des nouveaux pilotes
l'aéronautique un secteur qui fait rêver
les jeunes et qui de plus en bouche mais
attention avant de voler il faut avoir
les pieds sur terre
enfin certaines localités pour être
pilote de ligne en particulier celle de
pouvoir se remettre en cause pour
pouvoir s'adapter constamment aux
nouvelles technologies qui sont dans les
avions et qu'on a maîtrisé parfaitement